滴滴它是一个心理学的术语，
它的全称叫自恋型人格障碍，
我那天还认真又去研究了一下自恋型人格障碍，
我给你们再讲一下他们的特色了，
就除了我之前讲过的特色之外，
它还有很多特色，
可有意思了，
我老喜欢研究这些人了啊，
除了我之前视频里面讲过的NPD的人格特色，
他们死不认错啊，
任何事情发生了都是你的错，
他根本就没有爱别人的能力，
他能让你给他做饭，
让你伺候他，
让你跟他谈对象的话，
那就是对你的恩赐啊，
你能谈上他这么一个对象的话，
你就应该感恩啊，
哪怕他挣钱不如你多，
哪怕他社会关系不如你好，
哪怕他学历也不如你高，
一点也不影响他在家里面高高在上那个姿态。
还有他嫉妒性特别强，
他不会认为别人比他优秀的，
他认为别人挣钱比他多，
别人事业比他成功，
都是靠一些下三滥的手段才能够比他强，
他就是没出手，
他但凡出手的话，
他肯定就是那个最优秀的啊，
这都是NPD自恋型人格障碍的典型，
除了我刚刚说的这些之外，
他还有很多特色啊，
你们耐心听，
你们耐心去识别在你身边有没有NPD啊，
还有一个特色就是你不能批评他，
就你批评他的话，
当下他没有表现出来对你的愤怒，
但他在心里一定可记仇了，
哪怕你是基于说对他事业上的关心，
提出一些建议，
建设性的意见，
在他看来，
对他。
都是一种侮辱，
都是践踏他的自尊，
都是批评他理解吧。
所以以后啊，
你们啊，
对别人的事业上的事情，
对别人家的事儿的话，
就尽量不要指手划脚，
哪怕是善意的建设性的意见，
都要谨慎一点，
否则的话，
你不知道他哪一刻他就恨上你了。
再有一个就是NPD的控制力极强，
他需要通过控制身边的人来证明他是活着的，
证明他是有价值的，
证明他是高人一等的。
所以很多小事无伤大雅的事情啊，
干或者不干根本不影响的事情，
他就得控制你，
就得按照他的节奏来。
还有一个特色就是爱表演，
表演努力，
表演付出，
表演成功，
表演一个合格的父亲，
表演一个关心人的伴侣。
看上去他可忙了，
看上去他们一天可努力了，
一到年终算账没挣着钱，
有没有发现就NPD，
他就是这种特色，
就表演的可好了，
就是每天都觉得他为这个付出，
为那个付出，
实际上谁也没有得到他的好处，
每天都觉得他起早贪黑的，
好努力的工作啊，
一到年终总觉得没有挣到钱，
甚至还花你的钱，
有没有我跟你说这是NT地，
他会觉得全世界都对不起他，
他在自己的内心，
他真的觉得自己付出了很多，
他哪怕说想给你买个房，
他就已经觉得是对你付出了啊，
你怎么不识好歹？
他哪怕说承诺想要给你买个车，
想要钱，
挣了钱了之后，
赢了之后要带你过好日子，
他觉得就已经是他对你好的顶级了，
实际上你啥也没得上。
我就说我喜欢研究NPD吧，
因为他好玩啊，
因为他研究起来很有趣啊，
有没有谁懂我这个点，
特别需要别人的关注，
他交朋友啊，
就是说他不是说为了真正的深交一个朋友，
他只是需要普遍性的关注，
需要普遍性的认可。
他的自尊心的满足全靠进口，
必须要通过别人才能满足他的那个自尊心，
必须要通过别人的评价才能满足他心里的那个空虚、
寂寞、
冷的那个状态，
必须要从别人身上去吸食这些东西，
他才能活着，
喜欢画大饼，
他说了承诺要对你好，
他就已经觉得自己为你付出了全世界，
他承诺要怎么怎么对你，
承诺要给你买什么的话，
他就觉得他就已经是做到了，
你就应该感恩吗？
你怎么那么不识，
好歹可以向人讲NP。
再有，
她真的是感受不到你的痛苦的，
她不会说从你的角度来考虑，
她说跟别人的，
她回来劝你大度耶，
她不会感受到你的痛苦，
他说你怎么就不跟别的女的学一学呢？
你看人家那个张哥的老婆多大度，
人家张哥在外面都已经找了好几个了，
人家他老婆也没说要离啊，
你怎么有不跟正人家好的学呢？
有没有吧，
有遇见过的扣衣，
我跟你说，
我简直可以去演一个NPD了，
王菲姐多少是有点自恋在身上的，
我演他们肯定。
眼，
记得点赞关注哦。